the leroy neiman gallery is an asset to
leroy neiman center not only do we have
the fine art print studios in which our
work is created we can exhibit it in
this nice space central to campus that
everyone can see it's a great way to
show off our projects and everything
that weaves done and created over the
past 15 years one thing that often
surprises people when they walk into the
gallery and they see this exhibition is
that all of this work was created just
behind those doors we work with artists
all different type of artists and to
support the the center we produce these
prints to generate money for fellowship
for their students and it's a learning
center it's pretty much training the
students how to make work well I was um
invited to work at the newman center by
the artistic director to moscow Daniel
and it's quite an honor a because I'm
faculty here so I've been around here
and seen a lot of the projects come out
but be because it was a chance to get
closer not only to Tomas but also to the
office and the whole staff here at the
Nieman center and to work closely with a
lot of the students we invite artists to
come in to create an addition of friends
and they collaborate with our master
printer the MFA students work right
alongside them handle paper do whatever
they need to do but develop these unique
relationships which I feel like is
different from a lot of the other
professional print shops in New York and
in the country
perfect so we let it sit for a little
while it will dry can we flip it over
and that way the drips end up like
they're going up change the orientation
a little bit well I think one of the
unique qualities about the Newman Center
is that the students and the staff that
work here are all their master printers
I mean some of the students really have
a very significant skill set so you're
in a room full of very knowledgeable
people but at the same time they know
how to sort of play their role in
working with the designated artists so
when we really ask them to come to
collaborate with us the one thing we do
ask for them to do is to teach to help
us engage in dialogue with our graduates
into our undergraduate suits and these
are some of them are you know most
important artists of our generations
Kiki Smith is our first collaborating
artist in 1998 she worked with Tomas
through Daniel the artistic director and
the astronomy department here at
Columbia to create these beautiful
prints and every artist approaches it
differently and they always the one
thing they all have in common is that
they challenge us in terms of combining
processes broadening the definition of
printmaking what a print is how their
prints would be different than other
artists and I feel like this exhibition
gives a nice look at what is possible
what can be done in the Newman Center
the options available to an artist it's
collaborating with us in our studios and
I feel like it's a nice selection of
work that's taken place over the past 15
years there was a lot of room for
experimentation trial and error we made
mistakes we laughed at those we modified
them and made great pieces and I think
that's just a vibe here and that's a
very nurturing and positive place work
environment for artists to be in the one
thing about labor I see he would come
and I can sit here and said oh we're in
this museum that museum we're doing this
and that sits down and quietly listen to
all the list of accomplishment that we
did for that year and he just turns him
I said
you know what are you doing for the
students the leroy neiman gallery and
the leroy neiman's center for print
studies is one of Columbia's best-kept
secrets in a way we have this amazing
resource that is available to Columbia
community we have prints available for
purchase that are in museum collections
and many people don't realize the
possibilities that they could have this
work in their home